uh welcome back to sky news we start
with some breaking news we're just
getting uh information from the white
house uh and they are saying that
president biden joe biden has covet 19
they go on to say that he is
experiencing very mild symptoms
and he has started taking paxlavoid
in response to contracting covid they
say that president biden is going to
isolate at the white house
and during that time he will continue to
carry out his duties so that is
president joe biden testing positive for
covid 19 and just looking at this full
statement from the white house press
secretary which says this morning biden
tested positive for covert 19 he is
fully vaccinated and twice boosted and
experiencing very mild symptoms he has
begun taking paxila void consistence
with consistent with cdc guidelines he
will isolate at the white house and will
continue to carry out all of his duties
fully during that time he has been in
contact with members of the white house
staff by phone this morning and he will
participate in planned meetings at the
white house this morning via phone and
zoom from the residence
the statement goes on to say consistence
with consistent with white house
protocol for positive cases which goes
above and beyond uh guidance he will
continue to work in isolation until he
tests negative once he tests negative he
will return to work in person out of an
abundance of transparency the white
house will provide a daily update on the
president's status as he continues to
carry out the full duties of the office
while in
isolation um so that is president joe
biden testing positive for covert 19
and
vaccinated twice boosted mild symptoms
and will continue to carry out his
duties from isolation at the white house